programming throwdown episode 97 the holiday episode take it away jason hey everyone so happy holidays all the different holidays are celebrated around this time of year um as we do every year we're going to do a kind of combo giveaway and also um answer folks questions so uh if you have a question now's a chance if you're if you're watching uh listening to this live um you can put a question in that channel. And we will kind of alternate between kind of answering folks' questions and giving away prizes. And so we can actually give away the first prize. We're going to do – well, first I'll talk about the prizes.
Programming Throwdown 第 97 期，节日特辑，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，祝大家节日快乐。一年中的这个时候会庆祝各种各样的节日。嗯，像往年一样，我们要搞一个综合赠品活动，同时回答大家的问题。所以，如果你现在有疑问，这是一个好机会。如果你正在观看或收听直播，可以在频道里提问。我们会交替进行，一边回答大家的问题，一边发放奖品。我们可以先发放第一个奖品。我们先来——好吧，我先介绍一下奖品。
So we're going to do three books to the top three folks. That worked out really well. So you can pick any of our books of the top three folks that uh that worked out really well so you could pick any of our books of the show for 2019 um that that is available in ebook and we will um uh we will send it to you if you have kindle or any of those services uh we'll also give away three laptop stickers which is pretty cool we'll give away three t-shirts. And the way that folks can enter this, anyone who's a patron on our Patreon is automatically enrolled in this.
我们将为前三名提供三本书。这效果非常好。所以你可以从我们 2019 年节目中提到的书中任选一本，只要有电子书版本，我们就会送给你。如果你有 Kindle 或类似服务，我们也会送出三个笔记本电脑贴纸，这很酷，我们还会送出三件 T 恤。参与方式是，任何 Patreon 的赞助者都会自动获得参与资格。
So I'll be reaching out to everyone who's a patron. I have access to your email, so I can send you an email telling you that you've won in case you missed the episode. And we can just coordinate together to figure out how to get. All right. Our first winner. I don't want to say I don't know what we should say, but basically our first winner is Don R. So if your name is Don, there's a good chance that you won a free e-book.
我会联系每一位赞助者。我有你们的邮箱地址，所以如果你们错过了这期节目，我会发邮件通知你们中奖了。我们可以一起协调如何领取。好了，我们的第一位获奖者。我不知道该怎么说，但基本上我们的第一位获奖者是 Don R。所以如果你的名字是 Don，你很有可能赢得了一本免费电子书。
Any of the books of the show are good candidates. And so I'll be reaching out to you, Don, and we will get you set up with a book. Nice. All right. Congratulations. Yeah, congrats, Don. Do you have a question to kick it off?
节目中提到的任何书都是不错的选择。Don，我会联系你，帮你安排好书的事。太棒了。好的，恭喜你。是的，恭喜 Don。你有什么问题要开始吗？
Yeah, so I have some questions. I also have a topic I want to talk about at some point, but we'll see if we can work it in. So scrolling back through the history, because I'm a terrible person and don't actively read the Discord. I see there's some question, which I think is pretty easy. We can answer it quickly is if someone's trying to get started using Linux and wanted to pick a Linux distribution, they're looking for recommendations, but I'll also say, well, what do you currently
是的，我有一些问题。我还有一个想在某个时候讨论的话题，但看看能不能插进去。翻看历史记录，因为我是一个糟糕的人，没有积极阅读 Discord。我看到有一个问题，我觉得很简单，我们可以快速回答：如果有人想开始使用 Linux 并想选择一个 Linux 发行版，他们在寻求建议，但我也会问，你目前在用什么？
use? All right. So recommendations for Linux distros and what we currently use. Yep. So I'm currently running Ubuntu on my computers at home, but at work we use Fedora. And I think actually you can use Ubuntu at work, but we have this thing called Chef, and Chef goes and automatically sets up a bunch of things, distributes software.
好的。关于 Linux 发行版的建议以及我们目前使用的系统。是的，我目前在家里电脑上运行 Ubuntu，但在工作中我们使用 Fedora。其实我觉得你在工作中也可以用 Ubuntu，但我们有一个叫 Chef 的东西，Chef 会自动设置很多东西，分发软件。
It's like a workflow manager for IT. And our Chef is designed for Fedora. So I'm running Fedora at work, running Ubuntu at home. And that's what I'm running. As far as which distro I recommend, I have tried almost all of them or a lot of them at various points in time. I think Gen 2 is fun,
它就像一个 IT 工作流管理器。我们的 Chef 是为 Fedora 设计的。所以我工作时用 Fedora，家里用 Ubuntu。这就是我正在用的。至于我推荐哪个发行版，我在不同时期几乎尝试过所有或大部分发行版。我觉得 Gentoo 很有趣，
but it's good if you're learning, but I wouldn't use that as a production system. It just requires too much maintenance. I'm a big fan of Ubuntu. It's pretty clean. It kind of gets the job done. It's built on Debian. It's pretty clean. It kind of gets the job done. It's built on Debian. It's pretty stable.
但如果你在学习的话它很好，但我不会把它用作生产系统。它需要太多的维护。我是 Ubuntu 的忠实粉丝。它很简洁，能完成工作。它基于 Debian。它很简洁，能完成工作。它基于 Debian。它非常稳定。
What about you? So I've mostly used Ubuntu, and I'm not nerdy about Linux. So for me, most distributions that are fairly popular, oh, I'm probably going to get in trouble. Anyways, mostly popular ones because they're the easiest to find help for. If you stay aside from any of the more esoteric ones unless you really want to get into um for the most part they're kind of equivalent i try not to over embellish my systems so that i can move easily between them um so i mostly use
你呢？我主要用 Ubuntu，我对 Linux 并不痴迷。所以对我来说，大多数相当流行的发行版——哦，我可能会惹麻烦。总之，主要是流行的那些，因为它们最容易找到帮助。如果你远离那些更深奥的发行版，除非你真的想深入研究——在大多数情况下，它们是等价的。我尽量不让我的系统过度修饰，这样我就能轻松地在它们之间切换。所以我主要用
ubuntu mostly because it's easiest to find answers and help for um i i know there's a number of interesting developments related to Linux distributions, which are better for containerization and the progress that's been seen as part of that. And I think that's pretty interesting. But yeah, I don't really have a lot of experience outside of, I guess I'd used Debian stuff before and then now Ubuntu. So I don't have, if you're never used it before, I don't know what would be like a good first, like install Linux on something and try it. I always recommend people put it in a VM
Ubuntu，主要是因为最容易找到答案和帮助。我知道与 Linux 发行版相关的一些有趣的发展，哪些更适合容器化，以及作为其中的一部分所看到的进展。我觉得这很有趣。但是，是的，我在这些之外确实没有太多经验，我想我之前用过 Debian 的东西，然后现在是 Ubuntu。所以，如果你以前从未使用过它，我不知道什么会是一个好的开始，比如在某台机器上安装 Linux 并尝试一下。我总是建议人们把它放在虚拟机里，
and just use it in the VM. Then you can use it from within whatever you're using now, Windows or Mac or, I mean, if you're on, I guess a OSX computer or, oh, sorry, Mac OS computer, you can pretty much, it's not technically linux but you can pretty much treat it like it is and learn a lot of it yep yep also like docker is awesome and vagrant is awesome both of those are um super super lightweight ways um to get a a linux you know system so like you could you could run docker and just do i think it's like docker run
然后在虚拟机里使用它。这样你就可以在你现在使用的任何系统（Windows 或 Mac）中使用它。我是说，如果你是在 OSX 电脑上，或者，哦，抱歉，Mac OS 电脑上，你几乎可以——虽然技术上不是 Linux，但你几乎可以把它当作 Linux 来对待并学习很多东西。是的，是的。还有像 Docker 和 Vagrant 也很棒，它们都是超级超级轻量级的方式来获得一个 Linux 系统。所以你可以运行 Docker，然后做——我想是像 docker run
ubuntu colon latest and just that one line will give you a bash prompt in ubuntu you can run that regardless of whatever os you're in and if you like delete the entire hard drive or something it's fine because it's just a docker image um yeah but that's not graphical. So you're really going to have to get your hands dirty. Cool. All right, let's do the next book. So the next person is Sean. So Sean B. I'm assuming it's Sean B.
ubuntu colon latest，仅仅这一行就能给你一个 Ubuntu 的 bash 提示符。无论你在什么操作系统中都可以运行它，如果你删除了整个硬盘什么的也没关系，因为它只是一个 Docker 镜像。嗯，是的，但那不是图形化的。所以你真的得亲自动手。酷。好了，让我们进行下一本书。下一位是 Sean。所以是 Sean B。我假设是 Sean B。
Oh, yeah. Oh, here we go. Yeah. So Sean, last name starts with a B. So Sean B, congratulations. You won an e-book. I'm going to be reaching out to you later on today, and we'll work together to figure out which book you get.
哦，是的。哦，来了。是的。所以 Sean，姓氏以 B 开头。所以 Sean B，恭喜你。你赢得了一本电子书。我今天晚些时候会联系你，我们一起商量你想要哪本书。
Nice. Congratulations. So before we get on to another question, we haven't done a news segment in a while, and although we've had various things floating around, I wanted to get your opinion on if you had seen the AI dungeon you know I saw that is that the one where it's like procedurally generated well so it's not procedurally so they used the what was it is it GPT yeah yeah the open yeah procedural isn't the right word but again they're using the language the the forward model from open AI so I'll give a brief overthink and then you can describe so most people have probably heard
太棒了。恭喜。所以在我们进入下一个问题之前，我们已经有一段时间没有做新闻环节了，虽然我们周围有很多事情，但我还是想听听你的意见，你有没有看过 AI Dungeon？你知道我看到了，那是那个程序化生成的吗？嗯，所以它不是程序化的，他们用了什么？是 GPT 吗？是的，是的，OpenAI 的。嗯，程序化不是正确的词，但他们确实在使用语言模型，来自 OpenAI 的前向模型。所以我先简单概述一下，然后你来描述。大多数人可能听说过
about it it got it's a fair number of i guess live streamers on youtube have been playing it to some hilarity um but if you've ever played a text-based rpg which go back to the dawn of computer games i guess although they still have a following today of new content being created. You would be placed in a world and you would have some set of actions you could do. And it's like a graphical RPG, but you just have to type in. And so it feels interesting
它，它在 YouTube 上有很多直播主在玩，带来了一些乐趣。但如果你玩过文字冒险 RPG，它们可以追溯到计算机游戏的黎明，尽管它们今天仍然有一批新内容在创作。你会被置于一个世界中，你有一套可以执行的动作。它就像一个图形化 RPG，但你只需要输入指令。所以它感觉很有趣，
because you're almost chatting with the computer, like pick up keys, look around the room, walk east, walk north. And so you're actually describing what you want to do rather than like pressing keys and hotkeys and making it happen, clicking with your mouse. And so someone took the GPT-2 model, is it? Yeah.
因为你几乎是在和电脑聊天，比如“捡起钥匙”、“环顾房间”、“向东走”、“向北走”。所以你实际上是在描述你想做什么，而不是按键、使用快捷键或点击鼠标。所以有人拿了 GPT-2 模型，是吗？是的。
And trained it on a bunch of these text adventures and RPG texts. And so it gives you that familiar thing where you're given a text prompt, but instead of a limited vocabulary of pre-programmed grammars that you could use, like a verb and then I guess it would be an adjective like walk east. I don't know. Yeah, I don't know either. I guess. No, it's I think it's an object, a direct object, I think. Anyway, so instead of having to put like a verb first where you choose from a dictionary and then, you know, a second set of parameters that you choose from, you pretty much say anything you want. So it'll give you, you give it, I think they have like some pre-canned scenarios you can do, or you can give it sort of like a seed sentence about like the setting and then it'll give you you know the first thing like you appear in a land filled
并用一堆这些文字冒险和 RPG 文本对其进行了训练。所以它给了你那种熟悉的体验，你得到一个文本提示，但不是预编程语法的有限词汇表，比如动词然后是形容词，像“向东走”。我不知道。是的，我也不知道。我想。不，我认为它是一个宾语，直接宾语，我想。无论如何，所以与其必须先放一个动词，从字典中选择，然后是第二组参数，你几乎可以说任何你想说的话。所以它会给你——我想他们有一些预设的场景你可以做，或者你可以给它一个关于背景的种子句子，然后它会给你第一件事，比如“你出现在一片充满喷发火山和硫磺味的大地上”，然后就是这样，你可以说任何你想做的事。
with spewing volcanoes and the smell of sulfur and then that's just it and you can pretty much say whatever you want to do um and the interesting thing is instead of having this limited that it'll try to respond to pretty much any text so if you say uh give myself a magical blizzard cloud over my head um it'll say snow begins to fall and melt into rain uh what do you do next and it's just sort of this interactive back and forth and it to me which is really interesting because although from the ai aspect i guess it's pretty interesting and the guy was running up huge server bills based on how he was actually trying to run the thing. He's from a university and it was just a project he did, I guess, on the side.
嗯，有趣的是，它没有这种限制，它会尝试响应几乎任何文本。所以如果你说“给我头上加一朵神奇的暴风雪云”，它会说“雪开始落下并融化成雨，你接下来做什么？”这只是一种互动的来回交流。对我来说，这非常有趣，因为虽然从 AI 的角度来看，我想这很有趣，而且那个家伙因为他实际运行它的方式而产生了巨大的服务器账单。他来自一所大学，这只是他顺手做的一个项目。
He was racking up sort of huge bills for everybody logging in and booting up these systems and loading these giant models and executing them. But just from the concept, it's fascinating because for kind of one of these first times, you pretty much just say anything and the computer will attempt to respond to you so it's almost just like a sophisticated chat bot and so you get these people sharing stories that they have with the computer where
他为每个登录、启动这些系统、加载这些巨大模型并执行它们的人积累了巨额账单。但仅从概念上讲，它很迷人，因为这是第一次，你几乎可以说任何话，电脑都会尝试回应你。所以它几乎就像一个复杂的聊天机器人。所以你会看到人们分享他们与电脑的故事，
sometimes it gives non sequiturs but if you kind of play along and are careful in what you choose it'll just respond back almost as if you're just talking with a friend. And I've never played Dungeons and Dragons with actual dungeon master, you know, person, but I kind of imagine it's like what happens there where you can say anything you want and there's like a set of rules where it tries to respond to you appropriately. But you never really see that in computers because it's just too hard. The universe of what people can say is just too big. Yeah, I think I think the part that and I haven't looked at it yet, so, so maybe I'm missing this, but it seemed like, uh, um, like you can't really win,
有时它会给出不连贯的回答，但如果你顺着它玩，并且在选择时小心一点，它就会回应你，就像你在和朋友聊天一样。我从来没有和真正的地下城主（人）玩过《龙与地下城》，但我可以想象那里的情况，你可以说任何你想说的话，有一套规则，它会尝试适当地回应你。但你在电脑上从未真正看到过这一点，因为这太难了。人们能说的话的宇宙太大了。是的，我想我想那部分——我还没看过它，所以，所以也许我错过了这一点，但看起来，嗯，嗯，就像你不能真正赢，
right. Or like, or let me make progress. I mean, it will let you win. Yeah. So, so like, what does it mean to win when you're making it all up as you go? Oh, like you could just say like, I just won and it'll talk about what a winner you are. It's like declare victory. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think so. But how do you win in life? Yeah. Good point. So, so this is the, um, this is sort of the quintessential AI question of our time, which is, you know, we had all of this symbolic, uh, AI, right. We have these expert systems and we had, you know, people writing millions of lines of lisp and um um and it's it's algebraic right and it's it's like a formal automata um and then we went to you know this new sort of deep learning where everything is now signal processing
对吧。或者说，或者让我取得进展。我的意思是，它会让你赢。是的。所以，当你边走边编的时候，赢意味着什么？哦，就像你可以说“我刚刚赢了”，它就会谈论你是一个多么伟大的赢家。就像宣布胜利。是的。是的。我的意思是，我想是这样。但你在生活中怎么赢呢？是的，好观点。所以，这是我们这个时代典型的 AI 问题，也就是，你知道，我们有所有这些符号 AI，对吧。我们有这些专家系统，我们有写了几百万行 Lisp 的人，嗯，它是代数的，对吧，它就像一个形式自动机。然后我们转向了这种新的深度学习，现在一切都是信号处理，
and there there are no symbols it's just like uh just this like crackles of energy flying around. And so this is a case where it's like, you kind of need to reunite those two fields. So like, there needs to be sort of some concept of, I don't know, a key in a door. And that can't just float away. Like it has to be sort of a part of the story indefinitely, right? And so that's, I think that's the piece that's kind of missing is you can't do the like problem solving and the game part of it without some type of symbolic yeah but it's it's it's amazing i mean i think it'll happen it's just a matter of time that's that's the cutting edge but i guess to me like the equivalent to dungeons and dragons is the
没有符号，它就像能量的噼啪声在四处飞舞。所以这是一个你需要重新结合这两个领域的例子。所以，需要某种概念，我不知道，比如门上的钥匙。那不能只是飘走。它必须无限期地成为故事的一部分，对吧？所以，我认为这是缺失的部分，你不能在没有某种符号的情况下做解决问题和游戏的部分。是的，但它很神奇，我的意思是，我认为它会发生，这只是时间问题，那是前沿技术。但对我来说，类似于《龙与地下城》的是，
you know from what i understand it doesn't have to have strong objectives like now there are end games for minecraft and stuff but i mean you just go in and it's just a sandbox you kind of just do yeah things like those are also valuable experiences without the conventional sort of quote-unquote game framework yeah that's a really good point i think i was looking at it through the lens of of of a of an adventure game when uh when you're right it's really more of like uh like a sandbox it's really a interactive fiction sandbox yeah that's so cool i'm i'm really inspired now i'm gonna check that out i think we should do yeah you should play it and tell us like recount the story yeah there was one
据我所知，它不需要有强大的目标，虽然现在《我的世界》等游戏有结局，但我的意思是，你只是进去，它只是一个沙盒，你只是做事情。是的，像那些也是有价值的体验，没有传统的所谓“游戏框架”。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我想我是通过冒险游戏的视角来看待它的，当你——你是对的，它更像是一个沙盒，它确实是一个交互式小说沙盒。是的，太酷了。我现在真的很受启发，我要去看看。我想我们应该做——是的，你应该玩一下，然后告诉我们，讲述一下故事。是的，有一个
where they trained it on news and you could give it a news headline and it would write the story that was hilarious um so you could you could say anything you want you could say you know the united states sinks into the ocean and it would write a whole story about it and it sounded pretty plausible yeah i mean you have to be generous because it's still like i guess early days um but if you forgive it and like go along with what it's trying to say i mean i think you ever read those i i read dwarf fortress stories sometimes yeah right yeah all of this from a few ascii characters on the screen and this person is spinning this giant tale of you know heroism from their mighty dwarves i actually installed door fortress uh about a
他们用新闻训练它，你可以给它一个新闻标题，它就会写出故事，那太搞笑了。所以你可以说任何你想说的话，你可以说“美国沉入海底”，它就会写一个关于它的完整故事，听起来还挺可信的。是的，我的意思是，你必须宽容，因为它还处于早期阶段。但如果你原谅它，顺着它想说的去，我的意思是，我想你读过那些吗？我有时会读《矮人要塞》的故事。是的，对吧。所有这些都来自屏幕上的几个 ASCII 字符，而这个人正在讲述他们强大的矮人的英雄主义故事。我其实在大约
couple of days ago just randomly i wanted to get back into it and yeah that learning curve is is brutal but it's all right i think some more giveaways let's do it okay so the next person is james james k um james k you are a james k has been a patron for a long time, which is awesome. Thank you, James. Thank you so much for your patronage. And it's paid off. You get a ebook of your choosing.
几天前随机安装了《矮人要塞》，我想重新开始玩，是的，那个学习曲线太残酷了。但没关系，我想再多做一些赠品。让我们开始吧。好的，下一位是 James，James K。James K 已经做了很长时间的赞助者了，这太棒了。谢谢你，James。非常感谢你的赞助。这得到了回报。你得到了一本你选择的电子书。
And so I'll reach out to you to set that up. Cool. We can go to the. Yeah. So I pulled a bunch of them out. So the next one out of there we had is that, sorry, some of the others I didn't write down the names of this one I did. So X386 was asking about learning Java data structure. And people were replying and sort of, you know, indicating that just learning general data structures as opposed to the specifics of Java.
我会联系你来安排这件事。酷。我们可以去。是的。所以我从中挑出了一堆。所以下一个我们有的是——抱歉，其他一些我没有记下名字，这个我记了。X386 在问关于学习 Java 数据结构的问题。人们在回复，并指出学习通用数据结构而不是 Java 的具体细节。
Other Java has some interesting ones. And what I'll say here is actually, rather than reading a book about data structures, although maybe that's good too, I guess it's hard to say. I read a book about data structures for a class pretty early on. So I guess I got exposed to some of them. But I would recommend learning a little bit about design patterns.
其他 Java 有一些有趣的。我想在这里说的是，实际上，与其读一本关于数据结构的书，虽然也许那也不错，我想很难说。我为了课程很早就读过一本关于数据结构的书。所以我猜我接触过其中一些。但我建议学习一点设计模式。
And if you really want some like beginning level stuff, we've recommended on the show before, but the headfirst design patterns book as a way to motivate learning about. I mean, I guess it's about design patterns, but learning about those design patterns will also introduce you to a number of data structures, which I think is pretty good. Aside from that, it's mostly task based. So like if you need efficient lookup, you know, learning about hash maps and the various things related to them or learning about linked lists, you know, it becomes more about like what you're trying to do and the specifics of it. But for a sort of more cohesive narrative that will force you to learn various data structures at a different level, I think design patterns is a good way to go. Yep. Yeah, I've read that book. It's, it's fantastic. I think it's a good way to sort of motivate the data structure with with a use case, instead of just trying to learn this library of data. But I guess if you were trying to do like, computer competition, or Oh, yeah, that's totally
如果你真的想要一些入门级的东西，我们之前在节目中推荐过，但《Head First 设计模式》这本书是激发学习的一种方式。我的意思是，我想它是关于设计模式的，但学习那些设计模式也会向你介绍许多数据结构，我认为这很不错。除此之外，它主要是基于任务的。所以如果你需要高效查找，你知道，学习哈希映射和与之相关的各种东西，或者学习链表，你知道，它更多地变成了关于你试图做什么以及它的具体细节。但对于一种更连贯的叙述，它会强迫你在不同层面学习各种数据结构，我认为设计模式是一个很好的方向。是的。是的，我读过那本书。它太棒了。我认为这是一种用用例来激发数据结构的好方法，而不是仅仅试图学习这个数据库。但我想如果你试图做像计算机竞赛，或者哦，是的，那完全是
tech company, tech company interview algorithm data structures. Yeah, I think just like any, pretty much any of the like popular data structures books are probably a good approach. The MIT one is pretty popular. But there's a variety of them. And I think any of those is good. And yeah, it's hard to get into,
科技公司，科技公司面试算法数据结构。是的，我认为就像任何流行的数据结构书籍一样，可能是一个好的方法。麻省理工学院的那本很受欢迎。但有很多种。我认为任何一本都很好。而且，是的，很难进入，
but I don't know of a way around that. Like you kind of just have to get exposed to a variety of things and learning them somewhat as like a puzzle. And then once you understand them, it sort of clicks and makes sense. Yeah, what I recommend to folks too is after that is to check out these coding sites
但我不知道有什么办法可以绕过它。你必须接触各种各样的东西，并把它们当作谜题来学习。一旦你理解了它们，它就会豁然开朗，变得有意义。是的，我也向大家推荐的是，在那之后去看看这些编码网站，
like HackerRank and TopCoder and look at the hard problems and read the solutions to them. And so if you read the problem, I mean, the problem is going to be fictitious, but it's loosely based in reality. So it might be something like routing mail or something like that. And then you can see the data structure they use, and it kind of gives you an idea of how that could work in the real world.
比如 HackerRank 和 TopCoder，看看难题并阅读它们的解决方案。所以如果你读了这个问题，我的意思是，这个问题是虚构的，但它大致基于现实。所以它可能是像路由邮件之类的事情。然后你可以看到他们使用的数据结构，它让你了解这在现实世界中是如何工作的。
Yeah, when you get to those kind of data structures, I guess maybe I've never really thought about it deeply, but the design pattern style, object-oriented designing and the data structures there is somewhat different than the data structures as entwined with algorithms that is the more like traditional computer science stuff. Yep. Yep. Yeah. design pattern could could use a data structure but it doesn't have to um but yeah i think they're both important for different reasons like one one will get you through the interview and the other so it's probably probably worth worth knowing both um so joe actually chat has like what are our guys what are our thoughts on
是的，当你接触到那种数据结构时，我想也许我从来没有深入思考过它，但设计模式风格、面向对象设计和其中的数据结构与作为算法交织在一起的数据结构（即更传统的计算机科学内容）有些不同。是的。是的。设计模式可以使用数据结构，但不必非要使用。但是的，我认为它们都很重要，原因不同。一个能让你通过面试，另一个——所以可能值得两者都了解。所以 Joe，聊天室里有人问，我们对
the pine phone or the LibRen5? Do you know what that is, PinePhone? Isn't it like a phone that's open source? Oh, yeah, yeah. Here you go. Oh, yeah. Okay. So, yeah, I could talk briefly about, you know, I use an Android phone.
PinePhone 或 Librem 5 有什么看法？你知道那是什么吗，PinePhone？它不是一个开源手机吗？哦，是的，是的。给你。哦，是的。好的。所以，是的，我可以简单谈谈，你知道，我用的是 Android 手机。
And I do have, what's it called, FDroid. And so you can install open source software. I was using this other thing called Aptoid, which would let you install, it's another third party, you know, kind of play store. And one of the things I noticed about Android is the phone just degrades quickly. You know, like my phone is two years old and it already has a ton of issues. Like sometimes the cell just is gone. Like I just have no 3G, like no cell, I can't call. And so I just have to reboot the phone. And it just seems like every time I get a phone
我确实有，它叫什么，F-Droid。所以你可以安装开源软件。我过去用过另一个叫 Aptoide 的东西，它让你安装，它是另一个第三方应用商店。我注意到 Android 的一件事是手机退化得很快。你知道，我的手机用了两年，已经有很多问题了。比如有时信号完全消失了。比如我没有 3G，没有信号，我不能打电话。所以我只能重启手机。而且看起来每次我拿到手机
after a couple of years, it has serious issues. So like right now I have the Pixel 2 XL. Part of it too is, you know, I'm not the most gentle with my phone. It kind of goes everywhere with you. I don't have a case. And so part of it might be self-inflicted. But yeah, I feel like if I go open source on my phone, it's just going to make those worse.
几年后，它就有严重的问题。所以现在我有 Pixel 2 XL。部分原因也是，你知道，我对待手机不是最温柔的。它随处可见。我没有保护壳。所以部分原因可能是自找的。但是的，我觉得如果我在手机上使用开源，只会让这些问题变得更糟。
I used to do a lot of just random things with the phone. But now I've started to just do more on the web. And so I'm just using less apps and just doing fewer things on the phone, or maybe another way of saying it is doing almost everything inside of the browser. And so I'd probably not go open source on the phone unless maybe, you know, it was super reliable, but open source is usually not good for that. What's your take, Patrick?
我过去常在手机上做很多随机的事情。但现在我开始在网上做更多事情。所以我用的应用少了，在手机上做的事情也少了，或者换句话说，几乎所有事情都在浏览器里完成。所以我可能不会在手机上使用开源，除非，你知道，它超级可靠，但开源通常在这方面不太好。你觉得呢，Patrick？
Yeah. So I'm looking here at the comparison chart between the Librem 5 and the Pine phone. I guess they're sort of the same, but also very different. So what I'd say is I love the sort of, you know, hacking aspect of a lot of this, but I don't really want to do it in this form factor. Yeah. This form factor seems overly cramped. So like hacking on a single board computer, like a Raspberry Pi or an Arduino or, you know, something like that. Those things would be interesting to me and I could do projects on them. If I'm going to do computer style work and write applications, I I kind of want to do that on my laptop or my desk.
是的。我正在看 Librem 5 和 PinePhone 之间的对比图。我想它们有点像，但也非常不同。所以我想说的是，我喜欢其中很多东西的黑客方面，但我真的不想在这种外形尺寸下做。是的。这种外形尺寸看起来太拥挤了。所以，像在单板计算机上进行黑客攻击，比如 Raspberry Pi 或 Arduino，或者类似的东西。那些东西对我来说很有趣，我可以在上面做项目。如果我要做计算机风格的工作并编写应用程序，我还是想在我的笔记本电脑或桌面上做。
My phone, I see more as, I guess I would say, like a video game console I would want it to be closer to, which is I want it that it works. I sit down, I do a thing, and it's good at what it does, which is being a phone and playing something. So I want it to be a curated thing also i mean just like the practical aspects like having a kernel panic or something happen on my phone when i'm trying to make a phone call doesn't exactly sound like fun to me yeah you know people
我的手机，我更多地把它看作，我想我会说，像游戏机，我希望它更接近那个，也就是我希望它能工作。我坐下来，做一件事，它擅长它所做的事情，那就是作为一部手机和玩游戏。所以我希望它是一个精心策划的东西。另外，我的意思是，仅仅是实际方面，比如当我试图打电话时手机出现内核恐慌，这对我来说听起来并不好玩。是的，你知道人们
i'm sorry oh yeah you know what would be really cool would be um you know changing the morphology of the phone like for example if I could make my phone look and feel like an Xbox controller with a screen in it. I don't know how that would fit in my pocket. I have to think that through. Basically, if the phone had real buttons and
抱歉，哦，是的，你知道什么会很酷吗？嗯，你知道改变手机的形态，例如，如果我可以让我的手机看起来和感觉像一个带有屏幕的 Xbox 手柄。我不知道那怎么能放进我的口袋。我得考虑一下。基本上，如果手机有真正的按钮和
an analog joystick, but it was all built in. I could 3D print the case of the phone and it had all of that. I think there are cases, though. That phone, and it had all of that. That's interesting. I think there are cases, though. That's like a phone as module or something. Yeah, I mean, there are those cases you can wrap around.
模拟摇杆，但它是内置的。我可以 3D 打印手机壳，它拥有所有这些。我想有保护壳，虽然。那部手机，它拥有所有这些。这很有趣。我想有保护壳，虽然。那就像模块化手机之类的。是的，我的意思是，有那些你可以包裹的保护壳。
There are the ones, too, where the phone clips in. That just is too clunky. But there are the cases that have the hardware buttons. I probably start there before going to an open source. So if I had a very specific use case, like I was very security minded or I was monitoring a lot of closed caption cameras and wanted like very specific, complete control over how my phone behaved for very specific cases
也有手机扣进去的那种。那太笨重了。但有带有硬件按钮的保护壳。在转向开源之前，我可能会从那里开始。所以如果我有一个非常具体的用例，比如我非常注重安全，或者我正在监控许多闭路摄像头，并且想要对手机在特定情况下的行为进行非常具体、完全的控制，
that aren't very in line with the mainstream, I think these would be cool. And I could see myself turning to one of them as a second device or even as my primary device if that was my thing in life. But for me, I guess I fit close enough in could see myself turning to one of them as a second device or even as my primary device if that was my thing in life um but for me i guess i fit close enough in with what most people want to do on their phone and the phone is very very like the android phones that come out from the major vendors the iphones from apple like i feel they a lot of time has been spent polishing off
这些不符合主流的情况，我觉得这些会很酷。我可以想象自己把其中一个作为第二设备，甚至作为我的主要设备，如果那是我的生活方式的话。但对我来说，我想我足够符合大多数人想在手机上做的事情，而且手机非常——像大厂商推出的 Android 手机，苹果的 iPhone，我觉得他们花了很多时间打磨
the sharp edges um and making them very well tuned for sort of the average use case. And so if you're anywhere close to the average use case, those phones are probably going to work really well because they're manufactured at such volumes and with such history. And something like this would be one of these open source phones would be really cool for a second phone or if you had a very specific purpose that was very far outside the mainstream. Yeah. One thing I'm surprised is that AR using the phone hasn't really taken off like there's some cool i've seen some cool use cases like i think in google maps if you're walking around you can actually uh it'll show the camera and they'll show the path like you know projected on the camera um but i kind of expected
尖锐的边缘，并使它们非常适合平均用例。所以如果你接近平均用例，这些手机可能会工作得很好，因为它们是以如此大的产量和历史制造的。像这样的东西——开源手机对于第二部手机来说会很酷，或者如果你有一个非常具体的目的，离主流很远。是的。有一件事我很惊讶，那就是使用手机的 AR 并没有真正流行起来。有一些很酷的——我见过一些很酷的用例，比如我想在谷歌地图中，如果你在四处走动，你实际上可以——它会显示摄像头，它们会显示路径，比如你知道投射在摄像头上。但我有点期待
that to be a bigger thing and uh um yeah it just seems like i don't know just seems like that there hasn't been as much uh let's say innovation in the cell phone but the biggest problem is yeah exactly sometimes i need my cell phone to be able to call my family or you know hail a taxi uber and if if it's just freaked out and in some sort of weird been the battery drained that's really gonna give me bad day yeah it makes sense all right so uh on to the should we do t-shirts or stickers next which one do you think is more valuable let's do one of each let's do so so we should alternate oh okay well so i've i've grouped people into three groups yeah i just don't know which with which tier uh we'll do we'll do We'll do T-shirts.
那会成为一件大事，而且，嗯，是的，看起来，我不知道，看起来手机并没有那么多的创新。但最大的问题是，是的，完全正确，有时我需要我的手机能够给我的家人打电话，或者你知道，叫出租车、Uber，如果它只是崩溃了，电池耗尽了，那真的会让我度过糟糕的一天。是的，有道理。好的，那么，我们接下来应该做 T 恤还是贴纸？你觉得哪个更有价值？我们各做一个吧。我们应该交替进行。哦，好的，所以我把人分成了三组。是的，我只是不知道哪个级别。我们会做 T 恤。
I think T-shirts are more expensive, so we can just go based on that. We'll let the economy decide. So Clayton T., who actually has also been a patron for an extremely long time. I don't know if it says. I'm basing that based on some information, so I don't know if I have the actual... I'll see if I can look that up. But from what I can see here, they've been a patron for a super long time. Thank you so much, Clayton.
我认为 T 恤更贵，所以我们可以根据这个来。我们让经济来决定。Clayton T.，他其实也是一位非常长期的赞助者。我不知道它是否写了。我是根据一些信息来判断的，所以我不知道我是否有实际的……我会看看能不能查到。但从我这里看到的，他们已经做了超级长时间的赞助者了。非常感谢你，Clayton。
And you're getting a t-shirt, which is awesome. So I'm going to reach out to you later today and send that your way. All right. You want to do another one? Another t-shirt or another question? Let's do another t-shirt. Let's do another T-shirt. Double. People. Yeah, let's get people dressed. I think it's like Maslow's hierarchy of needs, right?
你得到了一件 T 恤，这太棒了。所以我今天晚些时候会联系你，把它寄给你。好的。你想再做一个吗？另一件 T 恤或另一个问题？我们再做一件 T 恤吧。我们再做一件 T 恤。双倍。人们。是的，让我们把人们打扮起来。我认为这就像马斯洛的需求层次理论，对吧？
You need your T-shirt before you can ask the right question. Number one. James H. James H. is is a proud owner of a T-shirt. This is amazing. So first of all, I want to say, I mean, I'm looking at I have a spreadsheet here, which is, you all, I just want to say, I mean, I'm looking at, I have a spreadsheet here, which is, yeah, I wish I could tell you I'm some marketing guru or I know all about, but reality is we spend most of our time creating content. And so I don't spend a lot of time
你需要你的 T 恤才能问出正确的问题。第一位。James H. James H. 是一件 T 恤的骄傲拥有者。这太神奇了。首先，我想说，我的意思是，我正在看——我这里有一个电子表格，也就是，你们，我只是想说，我的意思是，我正在看，我这里有一个电子表格，也就是，是的，我希望我能告诉你我是一个营销大师，或者我知道所有关于，但现实是我们大部分时间都在创作内容。所以我没有花很多时间
looking at the patron dashboard. So this is a rare opportunity for me. And I'm just really overwhelmed by seeing just how many people have been supporters for for so long like years and uh and i think that's amazing so thank you so much james and everybody else um but james you're a lucky winner of a t-shirt and so we'll get that over to you congratulations yeah thanks to all the patrons and the people who uh do the audible subscriptions who uh respond to the advertisers and advertising and the people who buy from
看赞助者仪表板。所以这是一个难得的机会。看到这么多支持者支持了这么久，比如几年，我真的感到非常不知所措，而且我认为这太棒了。所以非常感谢 James 和其他人。但 James，你是 T 恤的幸运获奖者，所以我们会把它送给你。恭喜。是的，感谢所有的赞助者和那些做 Audible 订阅的人，那些回应广告商和广告的人，以及那些从
our Amazon links for the books of the show. All of that helps out. It's actually really awesome. Yeah. So not not edge or not. Nodge. Nodge has a question in the, in the discord.
我们的亚马逊链接购买节目书籍的人。所有这些都有帮助。这真的很棒。是的。所以 Nodge 在 Discord 里有一个问题。
How do we find the sweet spot between over and, and if you have like the And if you have an answer wherever you work, that is probably one of the hardest questions. I could take a crack at it, or do you want to? Yeah, you go first. Okay, I'll go first. So yeah, it's a really good question. I think, so one thing is if you can somehow measure the expected drift, I think that's really important. So we're actually going to talk next month. We're going to publish an episode with a person who's an expert on Agile and a lot of these sort of processes, software engineering processes. And one of the takeaways, kind of a spoiler, is that you want to really learn from the past.
我们如何找到过度和——如果你有——如果你在你工作的地方有答案，那可能是最难的问题之一。我可以试着回答，或者你想回答？是的，你先来。好的，我先来。所以是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我想，所以一件事是如果你能以某种方式衡量预期的偏差，我认为这非常重要。所以我们下个月实际上要谈谈。我们将发布一期节目，嘉宾是一位敏捷开发和许多这类软件工程流程的专家。其中一个收获，算是一个剧透，就是你真的想从过去学习。
So you want to sort of make the past, gather as much signal as you can from the past and use that to sort of inform the future. And so that's one way to do it. Another way is just maybe you have some common sense reasoning, like you know that you're releasing a new product, right? But find out sort of like how much entropy there's going to be, you know, in the future. And that will kind of steer you in the right direction there. So for example, if you're writing version two of something and the reason you're writing it
所以你想要某种程度上让过去，从过去收集尽可能多的信号，并利用它来为未来提供信息。所以这是做到这一点的一种方法。另一种方法是也许你有一些常识性的推理，比如你知道你正在发布一个新产品，对吧？但找出未来会有多少熵。这会引导你朝着正确的方向前进。所以例如，如果你正在编写某个东西的第二个版本，而你编写它的原因
is because version one is slow and clunky and has bugs, well, then you want to apply more engineering rigor and you want to maybe redo engineering rigor and you want to maybe redo the database and put a lot of effort there, right? You know, conversely, if you're making an app and you don't know if anyone's going to use it and you don't know how they're going to use it, that's not really a good time to be, you know, writing just like a ton of things to make it very highly scalable and available and all of that. And so I think knowing your audience and knowing the product is really key there.
是因为第一个版本很慢、笨重且有错误，那么你想要应用更多的工程严谨性，你可能想要重做数据库并在那里投入大量精力，对吧？你知道，相反，如果你正在制作一个应用程序，而你不知道是否有人会使用它，也不知道他们会如何使用它，那真的不是一个好时机，你知道，编写大量的东西来使它具有高度的可扩展性和可用性等等。所以我认为了解你的受众和了解产品在那里是关键。
That that was really going to give you the insight because, because you can't really, I think that you can't really like give the, you can't build the ultimate product on day one, right? you're going to have to adapt which means what you write now is probably not going to be the right answer no matter how well you engineer and so yeah it's a really good summary i mean no one has the right answer because there's not only one answer and like jason was saying i mean it largely depends on how much things are going to change and how well you're predicting what's happening. If you look at, to I guess play it by analogy, if you look at startups, they take funding, but they often pivot, right?
那真的会给你洞察力，因为，因为你不能真正，我认为你不能真正像——你不能在第一天就构建出终极产品，对吧？你必须适应，这意味着你现在写的东西可能不是正确的答案，无论你工程做得多好。所以是的，这是一个很好的总结。我的意思是，没有人有正确的答案，因为不仅有一个答案，而且像 Jason 所说的，我的意思是，它很大程度上取决于事情会改变多少，以及你对正在发生的事情预测得有多好。如果你看，我猜用类比来说，如果你看初创公司，他们接受融资，但他们经常转型，对吧？
They often think they're going to do one thing and then even the very successful ones end up doing not that thing. Yeah, like Slack. Slack was a IRC client that a video game company wrote. And then they realized that the IRC client was way more popular than video games. Yep. And I mean, you can go down the list of,
他们经常认为他们要做一件事，然后即使是非常成功的公司最终做的也不是那件事。是的，比如 Slack。Slack 是一个视频游戏公司写的 IRC 客户端。然后他们意识到 IRC 客户端比视频游戏受欢迎得多。是的。我的意思是，你可以列举下去，
I think Twitter was an in-company communications thing. Yep. Yeah. So I mean, lots of these companies pivot. So I'd say the same thing is probably true on smaller scales, right? Which is, however, err on the side of under engineering and over engineering
我想 Twitter 是一个公司内部通讯工具。是的。是的。所以我的意思是，很多这些公司都转型了。所以我说同样的事情在较小的规模上可能也是正确的，对吧？也就是，无论如何，在工程不足和工程过度之间犯错
is probably safer. But at the same time, I would say like each person develops a gut feel about their systems and their technology stack and what parts really have to get addressed up front and what parts can be delayed without ruining everything. But it's always a gut call. Like no one actually knows. Yep. Yeah, I totally agree. Yeah. I mean, it's something you'll just you'll just hone in on with experience. I mean, it's like any trade. You have to you have to just build a lot of stuff to figure out sort of the sweet spot there and get that intuition. OK, so last t-shirt goes to Scott G. Um, so Scott G, you are a proud owner of a t-shirt. I'm going to reach out to you, uh, later on today. Congratulations. All right. Uh, Sohn Hay, uh, on the discord a while ago asked for recommendations related to image processing.
可能更安全。但同时，我会说每个人都会对他们的系统和技术栈产生一种直觉，哪些部分必须预先解决，哪些部分可以延迟而不会毁掉一切。但这总是一个直觉判断。就像没有人真正知道。是的。是的，我完全同意。是的。我的意思是，这是你会随着经验而磨练的东西。我的意思是，就像任何行业一样。你必须——你必须构建很多东西才能找出其中的最佳点并获得那种直觉。好的，最后一件 T 恤给 Scott G。嗯，所以 Scott G，你是 T 恤的骄傲拥有者。我今天晚些时候会联系你。恭喜。好的。Sohn Hay 在 Discord 上前段时间问了关于图像处理的建议。
That's a big, big, big question. Yeah, there's a lot there. So I can, well, yeah, I mean, I can talk specifically about AI. And Patrick, you probably know more about the signal processing part of it. But for AI, the most popular ones are Detectron, which does a bunch of object detection. They have a model you can download, which has a bunch of different categories. Or if you need to train your own, you can do that.
这是一个非常非常大的问题。是的，有很多内容。所以我可以，嗯，是的，我的意思是，我可以专门谈谈 AI。Patrick，你可能更了解其中的信号处理部分。但对于 AI，最流行的是 Detectron，它做很多目标检测。他们有一个你可以下载的模型，它有许多不同的类别。或者如果你需要训练你自己的，你可以这样做。
There's one called Hugging Face, I think. Hugging Face is another one. There's another one called, I think it's literally just called Face Recognition. If you put GitHub Face Recognition, you'll find it. And that has an insane number of sorts. Actually, that is the most starred repository, I think, in all of GitHub. It's just called face recognition. And it does that thing very well. So, you know, in general, I would say that, you know, you should really try to use existing libraries. I mean, image processing requires enormous amounts of data and compute. And so transfer learning, you know, starting with one of these models is definitely the way to go.
我想有一个叫 Hugging Face 的库。Hugging Face 是另一个。还有一个叫，我想名字就叫 Face Recognition。如果你在 GitHub 上搜索 Face Recognition，就能找到它。它的星标数量多得惊人。实际上，我认为它是整个 GitHub 上星标最多的仓库。它就叫 face recognition。它在处理那件事上做得非常好。所以，总的来说，我会说，你真的应该尝试使用现有的库。我的意思是，图像处理需要海量的数据和计算能力。所以迁移学习，也就是从这些模型之一开始，绝对是正确的方向。
Even if you're building something specific, you want to start with one of these solutions. Yeah, I mean, I guess from the signal processing-ish side as a way to describe it, I mean, looking at OpenCV and just looking at various functions that it uses and how to interface them is a great way to start. I'm not normally a big Python person, but Python works really well for this because it's pretty easy to use OpenCV, open a file, apply blurs to it, understand how that works, dig into what that is really doing under the hood, the difference of doing them with convolution versus doing them in frequency space, right?
即使你在构建特定的东西，也应该从这些解决方案之一开始。是的，我的意思是，从信号处理的角度来描述它，看看 OpenCV 并研究它使用的各种函数以及如何调用它们，是一个很好的起点。我通常不是一个 Python 拥护者，但 Python 在这方面非常有效，因为使用 OpenCV、打开文件、应用模糊处理、理解其工作原理、深入探究其底层逻辑、对比卷积处理与频域处理的区别，这些都非常容易，对吧？
So thinking about those kinds of things, but even just understanding like how the image data is stored, how do you change channels? How would you swap red and green? What does that do? How is the image represented in memory? It's a very far stretch from what Jason was just describing. But I mean, I think these things come up, at least in my career, have come up reasonably often, where knowing how, I mean, ultimately, they're big matrices, I guess that's a spoiler. Yeah, you know, like understanding what those matrices represent, how to manipulate them is a generally pretty useful skill um and so thinking through how that works playing around with it on your own trying to do your own like for instance uh writing your own function to convert a red green blue image into a grayscale image um how do you weight various channels like working through that
所以，思考这些问题，甚至只是理解图像数据是如何存储的，如何改变通道？如何交换红色和绿色？这样做会产生什么效果？图像在内存中是如何表示的？这与 Jason 刚才描述的内容相差甚远。但我的意思是，这些问题在我的职业生涯中经常出现，了解这些东西——归根结底，它们就是大矩阵，这算是个剧透吧。是的，理解这些矩阵代表什么，如何操作它们是一项非常有用的技能。所以，思考它是如何工作的，自己动手尝试，比如编写自己的函数将红绿蓝图像转换为灰度图像，如何加权各个通道，通过这些实践来学习。
although it seems like really redundant and why would you not just use, oh, maybe you don't even know, but there's a standard like balance of the channels to use to replicate what the human vision sees. But I mean, like working through on your own and understanding what that does actually teaches you a lot. And then there's all sorts of tangents,
虽然这看起来非常多余，你可能会想为什么不直接使用现成的，哦，也许你甚至不知道，但确实有一种标准的通道平衡比例，可以用来模拟人类视觉所看到的效果。但我的意思是，自己动手实践并理解其原理，实际上能让你学到很多。而且还会引出各种各样的分支话题，
not even getting into the sort of machine learning image recognition part of it, but just doing things like understanding barrier masks and debarrying and what did various filter, like not every camera uses the same image filters for the red, green, and blue channels. How does that impact things? It's a completely different way to take it, but it's enormously fascinating and people spend their careers, you know, thinking about those kinds of things. So yeah, I mean, there's lots and lots and lots of ways to take it. It depends. I would say do something which you find interesting cause it'll keep you
甚至还没涉及到机器学习图像识别的部分，仅仅是理解拜耳滤镜（Bayer masks）和去马赛克（demosaicing），以及各种滤镜的作用——并不是每台相机都对红、绿、蓝通道使用相同的图像滤镜。这会产生什么影响？这是一个完全不同的切入点，但非常引人入胜，人们花了一辈子的时间在思考这些问题。所以，是的，有很多很多种切入方式。这取决于你。我会说，做一些你觉得有趣的事情，因为这会让你保持
motivated. Yeah, that's such a good point. Yeah, totally. And, and I think yeah, having, having a sort of goal in mind is, is, is really important, especially for things like image processing. Cause you might say, well, I want to be able to recognize absolutely everything. And those are super, super hard open problems. It's much better if you can start with like, yeah, I want to distinguish these three things. I'll give a shout out to one specific project here because I'm doing the hardware thing. It's my shtick, I guess.
动力。是的，这观点太棒了。完全同意。而且，我认为有一个目标在心中是非常重要的，特别是在图像处理这类事情上。因为你可能会说，我想能够识别绝对所有东西。那些是超级超级难的开放性问题。如果你能从“我想区分这三样东西”开始，会好得多。我要在这里特别推荐一个项目，因为我正在做硬件相关的东西。我想这是我的招牌吧。
And that is OpenMV. They call themselves the Arduino of machine vision, I think. Is it NV or MV? Machine vision. Oh, okay. OpenMV. So it's a little PCB that has a camera and a processor attached to it. And they have a really nice infrastructure built around it
那就是 OpenMV。我想他们自称为机器视觉界的 Arduino。是 NV 还是 MV？机器视觉（Machine Vision）。哦，好的。OpenMV。所以它是一块带有摄像头和处理器的微型 PCB。他们围绕它构建了一个非常好的基础设施，
for bringing in the images, doing common manipulation, streaming them out to your computer so you can see them, and really bringing it together with an IDE and stuff like you would see for an Arduino board. And I really like this project. I did the Kickstarter for the latest one and got it. I haven't had a chance to open it up and play with it yet, but it's in my short list of to-dos to play around with this i think something like this is a really interesting way to get started because how much does that cost visceral i want to say it's like uh harold i'll just look on the stories i don't
用于导入图像、进行常规操作、将其流式传输到你的电脑上以便查看，并真正通过 IDE 等工具将其整合在一起，就像你在 Arduino 板上看到的那样。我真的很喜欢这个项目。我参与了最新款的 Kickstarter 众筹并拿到了它。我还没机会拆开它来玩，但它在我的待办事项清单上。我认为像这样的东西是一个非常有趣的入门方式，因为这东西多少钱？我直觉想说大概是……Harold，我查一下商店，我不想
want to miss well roughly like is it a hundred dollars a thousand dollars yeah like i would say it's like fifty dollars oh man that's amazing sixty five dollars guess, for the H7, which is their newer one, the OpenMV H7, which is a lens, the board, the camera. It's not as cheap as an Arduino, but it's not. I mean, for like trucking it up to a learning experience and like with what you're getting with it, that's pretty nice. Yeah, I mean, $60 is amazing. Totally amazing. I'm going to get one of those. Yeah, so I think this is a good project to kind of play around with and sort of start interacting with these at a very low level.
错过。嗯，大概是 100 美元还是 1000 美元？是的，我会说大概是 50 美元。天哪，太棒了。65 美元，我猜，针对 H7，也就是他们较新的那款，OpenMV H7，包括镜头、电路板和摄像头。它不像 Arduino 那么便宜，但也不贵。我的意思是，对于学习体验以及你所获得的东西来说，这非常不错。是的，60 美元太棒了。绝对太棒了。我要买一个。是的，所以我认为这是一个很好的项目，可以用来玩一玩，并开始在非常底层的水平上与这些东西进行交互。
I wouldn't recommend running Detectron. It probably doesn't even work on this. I have to run a very, very small model, if at all. But if you want the sort of opposite end of this, like how hardware deals with images and low-level image processing, I think it's a great way to get started. Yeah, and you could always pipe that to your computer. That's exactly right, yeah that makes sense cool all right so
我不建议运行 Detectron。它可能根本无法在这个上面运行。我必须运行一个非常非常小的模型，如果能运行的话。但如果你想要这种相反的视角，比如硬件如何处理图像和底层图像处理，我认为这是一个很好的入门方式。是的，而且你总是可以把它传送到你的电脑上。完全正确，是的，这很有道理。酷，好的，那么
our first sticker winner is jason d um jason d is uh he's been a patron for a little more than half a year and uh you are a winner of a sticker i'll be reaching out to you to figure out how to get that laptop. Cool. So we have a question. Is it worth going back? This is from KZ Isme. Is it worth going back to school to get a master's, even if it won't necessarily bump my pay grade? I really enjoyed undergrad. Yeah, I really enjoyed undergrad. Is it worth getting a master's? So Patrick, you actually got a master's while you were working. Yes. And so what was it like getting a master's while you the sooner to your academic, like undergraduate that you do it, I think the easier it is not to say that it's impossible at any level. But I think it honestly, it really depends. If you can stay motivated to do it, going back and getting a degree might be worth it, right? It helps. I don't know how it would hurt other than it being kind of
我们的第一位贴纸获奖者是 Jason D。Jason D 已经担任赞助人半年多了，你是贴纸的获奖者。我会联系你，看看怎么把那个笔记本贴纸寄给你。酷。所以我们有一个问题。值得回去上学拿硕士学位吗？这是来自 KZ Isme 的问题。即使它不一定会提高我的薪资等级，值得回去拿硕士学位吗？我真的很喜欢本科生活。是的，我真的很喜欢本科生活。值得拿硕士学位吗？所以 Patrick，你实际上是在工作时拿的硕士学位。是的。那么在工作时拿硕士学位是什么感觉？越早进行学术深造，比如本科毕业后就去读，我认为越容易，并不是说在任何阶段都不可能。但我认为老实说，这真的取决于个人。如果你能保持动力去完成它，回去拿个学位可能是值得的，对吧？它有帮助。我不知道除了有点
expensive. But if it's offered through your work, I don't necessarily see it as a big risk of a thing to do. But also like having been a person who does interviews and looks at resumes, I don't really take it as a huge positive, like a person who's gone and worked for two years versus a person a year or two versus a person who's getting a master's degree i wouldn't necessarily prefer one over the other unless the master's degree was something very specific to what we did um but the same would be true if they worked on something specific to what we did now that's just sort of like my experience and what i've done with it yeah i know it varies a lot um but i would say in general if you're having trouble finding good work and getting hired my initial gut feels is not due to the fact of not having a master's. There's probably a few niches and specific places where that could be a problem. But the general market, I haven't seen different story. But master's degrees, I would say you maybe look at
昂贵之外，它会有什么坏处。但如果它是通过你的工作提供的，我不认为这是一个很大的风险。但同时，作为一个面试过别人并看过简历的人，我并不认为这是一个巨大的加分项。比如一个工作了两年的人，和一个工作了一年或两年同时在读硕士学位的人，我并不一定会更倾向于其中任何一个，除非硕士学位与我们所做的工作非常相关。但如果他们从事过与我们所做工作相关的事情，情况也是一样的。这只是我的经验和我所做的事情。是的，我知道这差异很大。但我会说，总的来说，如果你在找好工作和被录用方面遇到困难，我的直觉是这并不是因为没有硕士学位。可能有一些利基市场和特定领域会有这个问题。但在一般市场上，我没见过不同的情况。但对于硕士学位，我会说你也许可以看看
other stuff, look to get experience, it's probably cheaper and more time efficient ways to increase your hire ability than than doing a master's degree. That isn't to say you shouldn't do it, or that it has no benefit. I just think if you're doing it to improve your resume hire ability, I would probably not recommend it. So what is the benefit then? So I mean, I think the benefit is being able to do more classes. Most people, when they're doing their undergrad, don't get to try all of the different classes
其他东西，寻求获得经验，这可能比拿硕士学位更便宜、更省时，能提高你的就业能力。这并不是说你不应该去读，或者它毫无益处。我只是认为如果你是为了提高简历的就业能力而读，我可能不会推荐它。那么好处是什么呢？我的意思是，我认为好处是能够上更多的课。大多数人在读本科时，没有机会尝试所有不同的课程
and different specialties of computer science just using that as an example. So going to a master's degree, you could delve a little deeper into various topics, which you kind of didn't get to. And you might not in your first job have access to or second job. Yeah, that makes sense it's a really good going back to school after a few years like five ten years could catch you back up on developments or refocus you
和计算机科学的不同专业，仅以此为例。所以去读硕士学位，你可以更深入地钻研各种主题，这是你之前没机会接触的。而且你在第一份或第二份工作中可能也接触不到。是的，这很有道理。在几年后，比如五十年后回去上学，可以让你补上最新的发展，或者让你重新聚焦。
um you know doing it while you work right like continuing education that's that's always a good thing i guess um and you know i guess guess all of being equal between two people, having a master's degree is worth something. Yeah, I think it totally makes sense that, like, the, you know, you might not, you know, at your current job be able to do image processing, but you might want to gain that speciality. And so to get out of that sort of trap, um, you could, you could do the degree, but it's, it sounds like if you're going to do it,
嗯，你知道，在工作时这样做，就像继续教育一样，那总是一件好事，我想。而且，你知道，假设两个人在其他方面都一样，拥有硕士学位是有价值的。是的，我完全理解，比如，你可能在目前的工作中无法进行图像处理，但你可能想获得那种专业技能。所以为了摆脱那种困境，你可以去读这个学位，但听起来如果你要这样做，
you should keep working and take the extra year. Um, um, I guess it would take three years instead of two. How many years? I did mine in three years. I did mine in three. So I did one class. So that was specific to, I guess mine, everyone's a little different, but I did, three so yeah one class so that was specific to i guess mine everyone's a little different but i just did one class a semester three semesters a year and um did it in whatever 10 says 10 credits um but that varies i guess it's a it's a lot of work though right there's i don't want to say busy work but doing it while you work is hard because you might have deadlines on your you know job and then you also have a paper due. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I remember. Yeah. I remember exactly that having a deadline and a paper due on the same day. And it's it's brutal. But I think it's it's good to do it early when it's a lot of
你应该继续工作并多花一年时间。嗯，我想这需要三年而不是两年。多少年？我用了三年。我用了三年。所以我修了一门课。所以那是针对，我想是我的情况，每个人的情况都有点不同，但我修了三门，所以是的，一门课，所以那是针对，我想是我的情况，每个人的情况都有点不同，但我只是每学期修一门课，一年三个学期，然后，在什么 10 个学分里完成了它，但这因人而异，我想。但这工作量很大，对吧？我不想说是琐事，但在工作时这样做很难，因为你可能在工作上有截止日期，然后你还有一篇论文要交。是的。是的。是的。我记得。我记得完全就是那样，在同一天有一个工作截止日期和一篇论文要交。这很残酷。但我认为早点做是好的，当
the knowledge is still fresh. I feel like if you're going to do it, good to knock it out early. Oh, the other thing is, you know, in both of our cases, our jobs paid for our graduate degrees. And that's I think that's a that's a game changer. Right. So, I mean, if you have to drop 60K to get the master's degree, it's going to be pretty hard to recoup that. Again, it doesn't mean you shouldn't do it. It just means that, you know, it depends on what your goals are. Also, the story is completely different if you are trying to get like a computer science or related master's degree. And that's not a graduate degree. I think that's a whole separate topic. But you broke up there. Can you repeat that?
知识还很新鲜的时候。我觉得如果你打算做，早点搞定比较好。哦，另一件事是，你知道，在我们两个人的案例中，我们的工作单位都支付了我们的研究生学位费用。我认为这是一个游戏规则改变者。对吧。所以，我的意思是，如果你必须自掏腰包 6 万美元去拿硕士学位，要回本会非常困难。再说一次，这并不意味着你不应该去做。这只是意味着，你知道，这取决于你的目标是什么。此外，如果你是想获得计算机科学或相关领域的硕士学位，情况就完全不同了。那不是研究生学位。我认为这是一个完全独立的话题。但你刚才断断续续了。你能重复一遍吗？
I said, yeah, I think it's a completely different topic if your undergraduate degree wasn't in a computer science related field and you want to do your master's degree in a computer science related oh that is a really really good point yeah i've seen resumes where that was the case i do think in that case it makes a big difference yeah because because um i think you want to show that you have sort of the core you know cs fundamentals yeah i think that's yeah you're right i think the value proposition there is very cool. All right. So we can go to our next sticker winner. It's Daniel H. Daniel's been a patron for a little under a year. And Daniel is from a very interesting.
我说，是的，我认为如果你的本科学位不是计算机科学相关领域，而你想攻读计算机科学相关的硕士学位，那是一个完全不同的话题。哦，那是一个非常非常好的观点。是的，我见过简历上是这种情况。我确实认为在这种情况下，它有很大的不同。是的，因为……我认为你想展示你拥有核心的计算机科学基础。是的，我认为你是对的。我认为那里的价值主张非常酷。好的。那么我们可以进入下一位贴纸获奖者。是 Daniel H。Daniel 担任赞助人不到一年。而且 Daniel 来自一个非常有趣的。
What is the country code CH? So I'm totally going to out our friend Daniel here, but I just got to know. Switzerland. Oh, OK. That's not here, but I just got to know. Switzerland. Oh, okay. That's not as exotic as I thought it would be. But still, I mean, Daniel from Switzerland, thank you so much. Being a patron for a little under a year. And we will send a sticker your way.
国家代码 CH 是什么？所以我完全要曝光我们的朋友 Daniel 了，但我必须知道。瑞士。哦，好的。那不是……但我必须知道。瑞士。哦，好的。那不像我想象的那么异国情调。但仍然，我的意思是，来自瑞士的 Daniel，非常感谢你。担任赞助人不到一年。我们会寄一张贴纸给你。
I'll reach out to you to get a way to mail that out to you. Cool. So we have one more question from a while ago and five questions. But our last question that people have sent in to us is from Cheesy Taco. How to approach resumes and job titles? They give a little context here about, you know, they're basically doing programming on the job now. Excuse me if the summary is not accurate, but, you know, doing programming on the job now, but their job title doesn't really reflect that. And they're sort of worried about, you know, they don't want to say that they're a programmer as a job title because, you know, their actual job title isn't that at all, but it is what they do.
我会联系你，获取邮寄地址。酷。所以我们还有一个很久以前的问题，以及五个问题。但人们发给我们的最后一个问题来自 Cheesy Taco。如何处理简历和职位头衔？他们在这里提供了一些背景信息，你知道，他们现在在工作中基本上是在做编程。如果总结不准确请见谅，但你知道，现在在工作中做编程，但他们的职位头衔并没有真正反映这一点。他们有点担心，你知道，他们不想说他们的职位头衔是程序员，因为，你知道，他们实际的职位头衔根本不是那样，但这就是他们所做的。
And sort of how would they address that? So what would your recommendation, Jason, if someone is doing like scripting and programming and maybe even building applications at their job, but maybe they have a different title like researcher or, you know, you know, associate or something like just a generic title at maybe a commercial company. And how would you what would you do for the resume? Like, how would you look for that to be represented so that they're not lying, but they're also communicating what they're. Yeah, this is a very, very interesting question. Um, so the thing about job titles are job titles are the few things that are represented very clearly in a background check, right? So, so, um, you know, you can't really have a lot of latitude there. For example, if you're an accountant and you say you're a software engineer, well, let me give another example.
以及他们该如何解决这个问题？所以 Jason，如果有人在工作中做脚本编写和编程，甚至可能在构建应用程序，但他们的头衔可能是研究员，或者，你知道，助理之类的，或者在商业公司里只是一个通用的头衔，你的建议是什么？你会怎么做简历？你会如何寻找那种表达方式，让他们既没有撒谎，又能传达他们所做的事情？是的，这是一个非常非常有趣的问题。嗯，关于职位头衔的事情是，职位头衔是在背景调查中表现得非常清楚的少数几件事之一，对吧？所以，嗯，你知道，你在那方面真的没有太多的回旋余地。例如，如果你是一名会计师，而你说你是软件工程师，好吧，让我再举个例子。
If you're an accountant with three years programming in Visual Basic and you say, I programmed in Visual Basic for four years, that's pretty hard to verify. I mean, you should never lie about anything. But if you're going to do that one, you could basically get away with it. But if you're an accountant, you're a software engineer, and you go through the interview, let's say you even get the job, when they do the background check before they make you the official offer, that's immediately going to show up. So you can't really do that. make you the official offer, that's immediately going to show up. So you can't really do that. So you have the job title that you have. Nowadays, with so much AI in the recruiting process, there's going to be some companies that will filter that. And so I think that the job title, I think in some cases could be a challenge.
如果你是一名有三年 Visual Basic 编程经验的会计师，而你说你用 Visual Basic 编程了四年，这很难核实。我的意思是，你永远不应该在任何事情上撒谎。但如果你要那样做，你基本上可以蒙混过关。但如果你是一名会计师，你是软件工程师，你通过了面试，假设你甚至得到了这份工作，当他们在给你正式录用通知之前进行背景调查时，那会立即显示出来。所以你真的不能那样做。所以你有你拥有的职位头衔。如今，随着招聘过程中有这么多人工智能，会有一些公司会过滤掉这一点。所以我认为职位头衔在某些情况下可能是一个挑战。
I still think that all of the things that we mentioned for folks who are students or in school, they still apply. So you're having a good GitHub account, a presence, having a portfolio, taking some MOOCs, doing some classes. We had a show with the director at Udacity, so doing some Udacity classes. Those are all stellar. And obviously writing what you do under your job title and your resume. But yeah, I think that is
我仍然认为我们为学生或在校生提到的所有建议仍然适用。所以拥有一个好的 GitHub 账户、存在感、拥有作品集、参加一些 MOOC、上一些课程。我们和 Udacity 的总监做过一期节目，所以参加一些 Udacity 的课程。这些都很棒。显然，在你的简历中写下你在职位头衔下所做的事情。但是的，我认为那是
one of the big challenges and i think in general a piece of advice i've heard is is is kind of do what the company does so in other words if you're a software developer try to join a company where software is kind of their focus um and so and so that will prevent that that kind of misalignment um but yeah what's what's your take on it yeah i agree i i would say for me i think there's a lot of latitude in how you do your resume so as jason pointed out you should never lie it's going to end poorly um in most cases many cases um and so i think what you can do though is you i've seen people do is uh even within a single position
一个巨大的挑战，而且我认为总的来说，我听到的一个建议是，做公司所做的事情。换句话说，如果你是一名软件开发人员，尝试加入一家以软件为核心的公司，这样就可以防止那种错位。但是的，你对此有什么看法？是的，我同意。我会说对我来说，我认为在如何制作简历方面有很多回旋余地。正如 Jason 指出的，你永远不应该撒谎，这会以糟糕的结局告终……在大多数情况下，许多情况下。所以我认为你可以做的是，我见过人们这样做，即使是在同一个职位上
at a company list out like projects they worked on and what their role was on that project um and then maybe under that so if you imagine like uh you know having sections and you know you're having like bold the company you work at and to the right of it having what you did on that project like maybe you were a tech lead maybe you were a programmer maybe you were an architect right right, saying something like that. And then underneath the like that part, like to the left, you know, maybe or under just saying, like, title, you know, whatever your current title is, or even, you know, people might put software engineer level three or so I've seen people do this on their resume, I think that might be a good form to take if this is your thing. So if you actually are legitimately doing
在公司里，列出他们参与的项目以及他们在该项目中的角色。然后也许在下面，所以如果你想象一下，比如，有各个部分，你把工作的公司加粗，在右边写上你在那个项目中做了什么，比如你可能是技术主管，你可能是程序员，你可能是架构师，对吧，说类似的话。然后在那个部分下面，比如在左边，或者在下面只是写上，比如，头衔，你知道，你当前的头衔是什么，或者甚至，你知道，人们可能会在简历上写软件工程师三级之类的，我见过人们这样做，我认为如果这是你的情况，这可能是一个很好的形式。所以如果你确实是在合法地做
programming, and you want to say, like, you know, application developer as your like role, but your position also included your title just so that it's not confusing or ambiguous and just call it out sort of like at the bottom of the section or like in a sort of subheading, then I think I don't, I don't know that that would be a problem. Like I, it's completely honest. And as Jason pointed out, people who use keyword screening or whatever, it won't take issue with that. It's not going to screen you out because you say your title is something different. And you'll make sure to get screened in by having the right keywords. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Totally makes sense. as long as you have the job title in there, then, you know, the person who's doing the background
编程，并且你想说，比如，应用程序开发人员作为你的角色，但你的职位也包括了你的头衔，只是为了不让人困惑或模棱两可，然后在该部分的底部或副标题中提出来，那么我认为，我不知道那会是一个问题。这完全是诚实的。正如 Jason 指出的，使用关键词筛选的人，不会对此有异议。它不会因为你说你的头衔不同而把你筛选掉。而且你会通过拥有正确的关键词来确保被筛选进来。是的，这完全有道理。完全有道理。只要你在里面有职位头衔，那么，你知道，做背景调查的人，
check, it's a third-party company. And what they're going to do is they're going to look at your resume and they're going to look at the job title that is coming from your former employer and they're going to look for a match. And as long as that matches anywhere they're gonna they're gonna say that's fine right um so so yeah i think that's i think putting it framing framing your your your job title um is is is the right answer there that's a solid answer sweet cool all right let's do the last sticker and then we can answer a few more questions um um you know time permitting but but so, so Devin C Devin C has been a patron for two years. Um, thank you so much, Devin. And, uh, you are getting a sticker. Very cool. And yeah, I think that's all the questions we have so far from the, from the discord. So
那是一家第三方公司。他们要做的是查看你的简历，查看你前雇主提供的职位头衔，并寻找匹配项。只要匹配，他们就会说没问题。对吧。所以，是的，我认为那是……我认为构建你的职位头衔是正确的答案。这是一个扎实的答案。甜，酷。好的，让我们做最后一个贴纸，然后我们可以回答更多问题，如果时间允许的话。但所以，Devin C，Devin C 已经担任赞助人两年了。嗯，非常感谢你，Devin。而且，你得到了一张贴纸。非常酷。是的，我认为这就是我们目前从 Discord 收到的所有问题。所以
if you have any more from email you had, or if you want to just go and finish up the giveaways and this up and wish everyone a happy new year. Yeah, actually. Well, there's, I'll just go through. There's a couple of questions that are pretty short. Someone said, did I get sweaty when Eternal Terminal was on Hacker News front page? I got a lot of emails. I didn't know it was on Hacker News until until somebody somebody told me. So I wasn't the one who posted it. So so that was kind of a surprise. I was actually driving back from a family vacation at the southern part of the state.
如果你还有更多来自电子邮件的问题，或者如果你想直接结束赠品并祝大家新年快乐。是的，实际上。好吧，我会过一遍。有几个问题很短。有人问，当 Eternal Terminal 在 Hacker News 头版时，我是否感到紧张？我收到了很多电子邮件。我不知道它在 Hacker News 上，直到有人告诉我。所以我不是发布它的人。所以那是一个惊喜。我当时实际上正从该州南部的家庭度假开车回来。
And so I was in the car and I got this message like, hey, you're at the top of Hacker News. And then I checked my email and there was a ton of emails. It was pretty cool. You know, I didn't I didn't get sweaty. But I'll tell you a story where when I didn't think there were that many people at my where I work using Eternal Terminal, I was pretty cavalier about rolling out updates. have to like update the server but then also support the older clients or you have to basically update everything at once and then kick everyone out and then say hey you need to update your client and so in the beginning it just made a lot more sense to do that this actually gets back to the over engineering thing um you know we were making so many changes and learning a lot about what it meant to write sort of a good remote terminal that it didn't make sense to keep around old version. And at one point, we released a bad
所以我当时在车里，收到了这条消息，说“嘿，你在 Hacker News 的头条上”。然后我检查了我的电子邮件，收到了大量的邮件。这很酷。你知道，我没有感到紧张。但我会告诉你一个故事，当我不认为我工作的地方有那么多人使用 Eternal Terminal 时，我对发布更新非常漫不经心。必须更新服务器，但也要支持旧客户端，或者你必须基本上一次性更新所有内容，然后把每个人踢出去，然后说“嘿，你需要更新你的客户端”。所以一开始，这样做更有意义。这实际上回到了过度工程的问题上。你知道，我们做了太多的改变，并学到了很多关于编写一个好的远程终端意味着什么的知识，所以保留旧版本没有意义。有一次，我们发布了一个糟糕的
version and something like 300 people couldn't remote into their machine. And that was terrifying. So there's been some times where things did get pretty terrifying. But the good thing is, you know, it's been three years since we started Eternal Terminal. And so at this point, it's mature enough that, you know, even though there's a ton of people coming, most of them were able to just start using it. I think it helped that someone someone asked oh someone asked how do you deal with having a single like how do how do you handle extremely large repos i've read about google having a mono um so a lot of these companies yeah have one single repository for the whole company um but but they're not using just regular git um they're they're they've often forked something like Mercurial or Git, but they have their own version. And so
版本，大约 300 人无法远程连接到他们的机器。那太可怕了。所以确实有几次事情变得非常可怕。但好消息是，你知道，距离我们开始 Eternal Terminal 已经三年了。所以此时，它已经足够成熟，你知道，即使有大量的人涌入，他们中的大多数人也能够直接开始使用它。我认为有人问“你如何处理拥有一个单一的，比如你如何处理超大型仓库？我读过关于 Google 有一个单体仓库……”所以很多这些公司，是的，整个公司都有一个单一的仓库。但他们使用的不是普通的 Git，他们通常分叉了像 Mercurial 或 Git 这样的东西，但他们有自己的版本。所以
you can check out just parts of the repo. And so you could think of it, you could imagine it as like a repo, but every subdirectory can be its own repo if you want it to. There's also like shadow file systems. The short answer is it's actually, it's a huge technical challenge to have a huge mono repo. And so it's, I'm kind of surprised that there isn't a product out there that, that enables that. But I guess the reason is there just aren't that many people who have, I think Google has like 14 billion lines of code or something. And there just aren't that many companies that have that much code that you know a mono repo becomes that's i think that's all the questions did i did we miss any of them or i don't think so
你可以只检出仓库的一部分。所以你可以把它想象成一个仓库，但如果你愿意，每个子目录都可以是它自己的仓库。还有像影子文件系统之类的东西。简短的回答是，拥有一个巨大的单体仓库实际上是一个巨大的技术挑战。所以我有点惊讶没有一个产品能实现这一点。但我猜原因只是没有那么多人拥有，我认为 Google 有大约 140 亿行代码之类的。而且没有那么多公司拥有那么多的代码，以至于单体仓库变得……我认为这就是所有的问题。我们错过了什么吗？或者我不这么认为
but it's possible yeah someone said um so yeah i think oh someone posted the face recognition it's called um i'll put a link in the show notes but yeah the the repo is called face recognition actually does have the most stars on github has 30,000 stars, which might be the most image processing. Cool. I think that's it. Should we wrap it up? All right. Well, thanks, everyone. It's been a blast of a year. Yeah. Yeah, it's been totally amazing. It's, again, just astonishing to see the support that we have and to actually literally see it here in spreadsheet form is really exciting. Thanks again. You know, we have actually we already recorded one interview and we have some other interviews and other content lined up.
但这是可能的。是的，有人说……所以是的，我想哦，有人发布了人脸识别，它叫……我会把链接放在节目说明中，但是的，那个仓库叫 face recognition，实际上确实在 GitHub 上拥有最多的星标，有 30,000 个星标，这可能是图像处理领域最多的。酷。我想就是这样。我们结束吧？好的，好吧，谢谢大家。这是非常棒的一年。是的。是的，这太令人惊奇了。再次看到我们拥有的支持，并且实际上在电子表格形式中看到它，真的令人兴奋。再次感谢。你知道，我们实际上已经录制了一次采访，我们还有其他采访和其他内容排队。
That's super exciting. So we look forward to sharing that with you folks next year. All right. See you guys. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这超级令人兴奋。所以我们期待明年与你们分享。好的，再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。